bonjour Maxime Le flaguet merci de nous
parler ça me fait bien plaisir d'abord
ou non de tous les téléspectateurs
j'aimerais vous offrir nos sympathies à
vous à votre frère à votre mère c'est
gentil c'est un histoire que toucher et
vous le savez mieux que moi beaucoup de
monde
comment vous avez réagi à cette vague
d'amour littéralement lorsque ça vous
aura renversé
que j'ai quitté les réseaux sociaux je
peux même pas imaginer tout ce que c'est
dit là-dessus mais beaucoup j'imagine
j'ai réalisé beaucoup plus tard quelques
jours plus tard je me suis dit ah c'est
vrai il y a tous les réseaux sociaux en
plus j'ai perdu l'habitude de penser au
réseau mais ne serait-ce que les textos
les courriels qui rentraient ça a été
j'ai beaucoup pleuré je peux dire ça a
été extraordinaire vraiment
extraordinaire c'est touchant de voir
qu'il était à ce point aimer apprécier
ce membre de la famille pour beaucoup de
monde vraiment c'est ça qui ressortait
beaucoup fait qu'au-delà de c'est un
acteur connu et puis on salue le départ
de l'acteur mais c'était beaucoup salut
le départ de l'homme derrière l'acteur
c'est ça qui me touchait le plus en fait
les gens qui avaient perçu les qualités
de l'homme derrière les qualités de
l'acteur mais justement on a beaucoup
souligner les qualités de l'homme humain
travaillant il était à son affaire il
était très drôle il avait comme un
talent inné comme Papa est-ce que
c'était le même homme que moi ce qui
était aussi beau que papa qu'acteur ben
oui absolument c'est un excellent père
mais c'est pas le père n'est pas un
amalgame de tous les personnages
heureusement pour vous heureusement pour
nous heureusement pour nous c'est sûr
mais il était il était très drôle il y
avait une répartie c'est mais
c'est pas quelqu'un qui faisait des
personnages qui étaient il y avait un
type d'humour où c'était justement donc
dans la répartie des des mots d'esprit
mais aussi il comptait des blagues c'est
vraiment à la à l'ancienne donc nous
notre génération on fait plus vraiment
ça c'est moi des fois je sors une blague
à mes amis et puis Montréal qu'est-ce
que tu fais quand une blague c'est
l'histoire d'un gars qui rentre dans un
bar lui il était beaucoup comme ça puis
il y en avait une infinité puis il
comptait tellement bien donc donc il ne
faisait rire beaucoup c'est drôle parce
que Louis José Aude la journée on a
beaucoup parlé de votre père a dit ça à
la télé maintenant c'est le meilleur
compteur de blague que j'ai jamais vu il
était très très bon pour ça puis bah
comme père c'est un père extrêmement
présent
attentionné très aimant vraiment la
famille pour lui c'était ce qui était le
plus important en fait il en a beaucoup
parlé à la fin dans ces entrevues
dis-moi j'ai réussi ma vie j'ai réussi
mon métier je comptais mais j'ai réussi
ma famille j'ai encore plus fier de ça
j'ai réussi mon couple j'ai réussi
j'aime mes enfants j'aime mes
petits-enfants donc ça c'était vous le
sentiez que c'était quelque chose
d'important dans leur réalisation
je pense que pour tous les êtres humains
c'est pas différent des autres ils
tenaient ça à cœur et il s'en occupait
il travaillait fort pour que sa famille
soit bien il est extrêmement généreux
tu nous a appelé régulièrement c'est pas
tous les jours pour être sûr tout va
bien à la maison vous autres tout va
bien c'était très important il y avait
un tempérament un peu anxieux un peu
papa poule mon père fait que mais il y a
plein au lac Saint-Jean tout le temps
ses frères sa mère tout le monde pour
être sûr est-ce que tout le monde va
bien ok quand il est fait la ronde
d'appel tout le monde allait bien là il
pouvait ou s'ouvrir une petite bière ou
décompresser regarder son émission de
télé et puis il y avait une demi-heure
une heure de là jusqu'à ce qu'il nous
rappelle pour savoir si tout allait bien
encore il vous avait à vu tout le temps
et vous vous avez choisi ce métier là
le flaguer est-ce que à l'époque je
pense vous l'aviez dit vous vouliez pas
porter ce nom peut-être pour vous faire
un nom pour faire un autre chemin ça a
été comme mal compris donc ce choix-là
souvent il faut que je vous explique
mais ça ne te dérange pas c'est que le
flaguette je trouve ça juste plus beau
comme nom d'artiste c'est tout ça
s'arrête là puis les gens pensent ah tu
voulais pas être associé à ton père mais
c'est le contraire si je m'étais appelé
Maxime côté il y en a 10 000 Maxime
cotés au Québec je serai passé plus
inaperçu mais en m'apprenant le flaguet
il y a une famille de la guerre au
Canada et on aime voir en Amérique du
Nord parce que c'est sûr que Véronique
le flaguet Michel coté tout le monde
fait le lien tout de suite et en plus
que je ressemble pas au laitiers je
ressemble vraiment à mon père fait
exactement c'est juste je trouvais ça
plusieurs original plus beau puis ça
rendait hommage à ma mère en même temps
puis mon frère est resté sur le côté
quelque chose de beau aussi puis j'étais
ado puis il y avait quand même un truc
autour de 19 20 ans ou tu veux faire ta
plage justement puis
tu es pas tout à fait sorti de la crise
d'adolescence
sur mon orgueil un peu de jeune coq puis
je disais ok mon père va me coacher puis
finalement j'avais besoin c'est quand
même coach mais fallait que je puisse
sur mon orgueil un peu mais j'avais tout
à apprendre de lui évidemment il y en
avait beaucoup plus que moi mais je me
suis fait dans une entrevie à parler de
vous qui était fière là ça paraissait je
l'ai vu puis de bon appétit d'en haut
puis je l'ai vu c'est fier mais je pense
que oui je pense que oui c'est un métier
que ça prend sur toute une ville fait
que moi comme acteur je trouve qu'il y
en a dans ma génération qui qui moi que
j'admire c'est mais on est souvent très
mauvais juge de soi-même mais je pense
que tu es fier de moi effectivement
il y a pas gagné sur une chose c'est
qu'il y a une maladie très dure vous
l'avez vu malade vous l'avez vu
combattre comment ça s'est passé ces
moments
toutes sortes de façon parce que c'était
des moments tous différents les uns des
autres il y a des beaux moments à
travers ça et des moments vraiment
pénibles c'est
solidaire avec tous les gens qui vivent
de près ou de loin avec le cancer là où
on est proche qui vivent avec le cancer
ou qui sont décédés du cancer c'est
vraiment une maladie comme je dis à la
blague c'est pas un petit rhume c'est
c'est dévastateur vraiment là donc il a
été super fort mon père a traversé
vraiment appris à mourir j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui qui rassemblait toutes ces
énergies pour mourir dignement il
pleurait plus à la fin quand on lui a
donné le pronostic on lui a dit que
malheureusement la grève de monosseuse
n'avait pas fonctionné
que la maladie était revenue ben il
était il était solide c'était incroyable
c'était vraiment fait d'acier
et puis ce combat
ultime
vraiment pas non non
c'est pas mal puis pendant l'année de
traitement et tout ben il pleurait
beaucoup il était vraiment ici entre
espoir des espoirs nous aussi on
essayait d'être positif mais on rendit
chez nous le soir on des fois on
désespéré on n'avait pas on lui avait
donné 30% de chance de s'en sortir donc
c'est c'est peu mais à la fois c'est
beaucoup mais c'est pas comme 1% de
chance le tu t'attends au pire mais 30%
tu dis ah il y a quand même la porte est
entre
mais il était super extraordinaire il y
a plus de dire au revoir à sa famille on
a eu le temps de faire les choses et le
temps de mettre ces choses en or de
testament tout ça donc il y a vraiment
bien fait ça c'est
et vous vous avez eu le temps de lui
dire au revoir
exactement je pense à Jean-Marc qui nous
a quitté si tôt Jean-Marc Vallée j'ai
été dévasté par cette nouvelle là
donc oui je manquerais beaucoup à ça si
je me disais on a eu le temps et puis
pas mort à 50 ans il est mort à 72 ans
quand même c'est presque trois quarts de
siècle puis il y a eu le temps
d'accomplir beaucoup puis il y a une
belle vie qui était fière qui était
content qui est mort heureux et mort
serein bien pas souffert puis c'est
qu'on est reconnaissant
c'est un gros mot mais son héritage
selon vous qu'est-ce qui laisse
il reste tellement de choses nous il
nous laisse des valeurs incroyables de
famille de d'humilité aussi quand on
rencontre des gens de toujours tu sais
moi je l'ai vu sur les plateaux il y a
les saluer tout le monde il était connu
pour ça il connaissait le nom de tous
les techniciens
jusqu'à la stand de production et je
m'inspire beaucoup de ça aussi sur les
plateaux quand j'arrive sur un plateau
c'est important pour moi de parler puis
de critiquer des liens avec le monde
c'est un métier solitaire rédacteur on
est toujours seul puis qu'on décroche un
rôle ben là tout d'un coup c'est c'est
la clé pour aller voir pour être entouré
de gens se faire des nouveaux amis c'est
comme la clé pour le camp d'été mais ça
incite pas le rôle tu restes chez vous
et puis tu tournes les pouces
au Québec
millions de Québécois puis pleurer des
millions de Québécois et puis transmis
sa passion a tellement de gens puis à
toucher tellement de gens et aujourd'hui
donc en terminant il y a des gens qui
vont défiler ici du public ça doit vous
toucher énormément ce bon on avait
jonglé le gouvernement peut-être avait
jongler funérailles nationales ou pas
vous vous teniez pas non pas du tout on
l'a jamais demandé quand ça a été évoqué
je me suis heureux ça existe ce truc là
mais comme je disais aussi à mon frère
papa aurait sûrement voulu que cet
argent-là servent à l'éducation ou à la
santé plutôt que ces obsèques donc on
est super content c'est l'École
nationale de théâtre Fanny qui nous a
écrit ce qui est en lien avec le
monument national et qui va faire un
moment gracieusement parce que Brou a
joué ici au moment national donc c'est
vraiment super hommage puis on était
très content de ça
exam le flaguet merci beaucoup
les prochaines journées vous allez vivre
avec des des
émotions changeantes j'imagine là la
fierté aussi en même temps c'est lourd
mais
sans que vous avez eu le temps de dire
un haut au revoir tellement beau et
simplement vraiment on lui a dit qu'on
l'aimait puis qu'on est on le remercie
pour tout puis je les remercie aussi
tout les gens les Québécois les
Québécoises de pour cette vague d'amour
c'est vraiment hallucinant ce qu'on a
reçu puis ça nous a touché profondément
merci merci la prochaine